we found a pocket this is still
craziness I slide here we go
well show the audience that with this
blow go so the other day Jimmy Fallon
went on Twitter and apologized for a
sketch that he did on SNL about 20 years
ago where he was impersonating
Chris Rock I believe yeah Chris Rock and
this is a clip of it
yeah a little bit you're not allowed
clean yes please so even as sketch
you're not allowed to play your cast
mate yeah bhai he's black he's doing a
thing of Chris Rock yeah so you're not
allowed to do even that's racist huh
okay I don't think black people feel
that way I bet most of them would be
like wide but also there's got to be a
statute of limitations as well yes you
know they're in when you apologize you
give way to these morons and actually
make something and if we're if we're
gonna cancel culture anything which is
so [ __ ] stupid there's twenty years
ago and he's playing a character that
his his friend who happens to be black
is doing a spot-on impression but there
has to be some responsibility if we're
gonna get mad at it which we shouldn't
but we are the satellite life not too
anyways yes ability who put the sketch
together the writers wrote it they
filmed it and okayed it but it just
shows you the temperature of America at
the time like this corporation wouldn't
be jeopardizing the dollars and putting
this on the air if that wasn't the
temperature but an agent at the time ABC
university NBC Universal nobody nobody
when it was on and nobody today if you
really were honest yourself would say
this is this is Jimmy Fallon being
racist no no he was doing Chris Rock in
the sketches good friend it's a comedy
so he's playing Chris Rock so did he
what he asked you Rock though I'm sure
Chris was like why but then Chris also
has to be like well yeah I guess that
was made today of course drag the person
like that's not a thing
well no don't drive that's Romany it was
calm well I say just like there was a
time in place when it was culturally
acceptable maybe to do that for comedy
but by today's standards definitely not
but you have to take into account this
is 20 years we stopped out what about
what about Jimmy Kimmel playing caramel
oh there's that yeah there's countless
cases of but but that's
that's not what I'm saying is that it's
all context to say that that's offensive
in 2020 is only you're saying that only
because there's a small minority of
people mostly white by the way and super
left who are saying that this outrageous
blackface yes there's a history of
blackface and it's a racist thing I
think nobody's saying that there is
comic ception to a rule where somebody
is doing something where you know
they're not racist you know what this
isn't up but this isn't this isn't the
problem the problem of real prom would
be the young african-american who was
killed by the cop that's a problem right
Jamie that's right
falen doing this 20 years ago of a skit
of his friend of Chris Rock yeah see not
one big bad not the wrong if someone did
that today yes I think people are there
there yeah they're projecting they are
thinking that this was made yesterday or
emotionally they believe that to be true
but you have to add context to it
understand this was done 20 years ago
and by today's standards yeah that's
kind of you wouldn't do that but society
has evolved and you have to factor that
in I can't believe the book this is a
conversation where people like Oh Jimmy
Fallon should lose his job over you guys
would you guys cancel would you guys
take the Constitution in the Bill of
Rights and throw it away which is given
birth to the longest-standing democracy
the world's ever known
and and and has actually the language in
that those two documents are used to
liberate marginalized people and were
used to marginalize and abolish slavery
etc the founding fathers were slave
owners a lot of them does that mean that
we tasted yeah does that mean and they
were I'm sure racist and by but does
that mean we take what they created that
incredible document and it has no
validity no you have to separate the man
from from his work obviously there are
inconsistencies like you said
historically there were his store there
a historical incident this is he there
are there are inconsistencies in human
as well the thing is you can only be as
woke as the year you're in yeah so the
standards you have today you can't apply
them to like a hundred years ago well
how far we gonna go back yeah but if you
can go 20 where's the limit we're gonna
stop well what about Picasso who treated
women like [ __ ] or Hemingway and women
like that do you want to get rid of all
this art yeah do we want
rid of all Hemingway's writing well I'm
curious so I guess you have to be a
saint you have to be a perfect Saint and
to to to do anything worthwhile because
anything you do I guess Woody Allen's
movies I don't think you know first of
all but let's just say whatever it is
there are people who create genius works
of art like dolly who are ghastly people
mm-hmm who are who I wouldn't sleep are
lastly person or anything
what about Michael Jackson so he's never
proved in the court of law that he was a
child molester or a pedophile so should
we not plays music anymore because those
accusations well the greatest joke
stillbirths greatest joke as he goes if
he did [ __ ] the kids we're still gonna
have to come to terms with the fact that
he wrote thriller and that's [ __ ]
genius I hope I don't give his joke away
head did he put that on special all
right or no probably I don't know yeah I
think MJ stuff is just so embedded in
the culture of the world that you can't
remove it like you can cancel Kevin
Spacey you can try to like remove
r.kelly
but MJ it's impossible you know what I
mean why why would you there's either he
was never proven a court of law
yeah if you if you go back and look at
all the all the articles that when you
actually look into it like what about
woody allen one way his stepdaughter
when she was seven had a memory seven
and and he in two court cases he was
exonerated but yet we're gonna cancel
him completely out there are a lot of
these things were hard want to seem
piece of [ __ ] there's we know we know
who the pieces of [ __ ] are Bill Cosby
you got twenty sixty women come on come
on we know what we know the truth you
know we know what you did [ __ ]
you got to be in jail 100 percent 100
percent me see this video sure rap now
we're talking where is it man oh man
I see who wants to be a millionaire
guess what not a lot of black folks on
this show right a lot of black I
remember when this aired I love us I
know I grew up on it and it what there
wasn't a fervor at the time looking at
it now you're like you know yeesh
yeah after but that time you didn't
think of it yeah it was just like oh
that's a great Chris Rock yeah I think
what sounds a little what's happening is
um you know younger kids are discovering
these clips like it's new to them and
they don't realize that it was remember
they do but they're not thinking about
it that this is 20 years ago and the
world grows and evolves and think wow
God were in a better place because you
have to trying to find racists it's like
it's like a headhunting thing it's like
find the races and get in you get aboard
of campus you know you becomes your get
you get you get social points for it
yeah they get validation yes you get
social points for beginning they're so
unhappy with their lives we get [ __ ]
over Jimmy Fallon look at this meetup
for Ruben trying to talk at a college
and these people are getting on with
black lives matter black they won't
listen they're trying to drown them out
it's not helpful this is this is
actually not how you combat racism yeah
there is real racism it's nothing like
it's like choosing your battles there's
like way more than something made 20
years ago yeah that's that's a problem
yeah you want it you want to protest
anything make a fuss about that would be
something to make up no it's amazing is
that this [ __ ] keeps on happening like
the video after video you think like how
long have cell phone cameras been around
and all that and like they keep this
stuff like this keeps on happening what
and it's scary but it you know when
Colin Kaepernick took a knee this was
exactly why I took a knee when we
dissolve he's anti-americans
anti-military is like no I'm not I'm
bringing awareness to how black people
are marginalized and how if they're
oppressed
against police that's why I'm taking it
isn't it crazy how everyone has a camera
in their pocket and this shit's still
going on
can you imagine what life was like with
no cell phones in the day well that was
a Rodney King thing this is going black
who said we've been dealing with this
forever
yeah like later Adi King thing was that
was a momentous moment in American
history because a lot of black community
were like you think that's [ __ ] new
for us we've been dealing with that [ __ ]
forever and they have so you know you
can understand the frustrations is this
it was him
Nablus yeah Minneapolis I can't even if
I can you know why yeah it's like new
ones will come up and I just can't hit
play on this thing I'll read the stories
watch that guy kneeling on his neck like
that for multiple minutes like - some
people say some people say five either
way that's wrong now again that guy died
in my opinion that guy should be that
police officer I'll do my hard job they
have but that right there you're a
[ __ ] idiot you should go to jail all
yeah all four should be on trial for
murder
all four just sitting there watching how
does one of them I go Dukey office
[ __ ] that here's I say well how are
you not here's here's what I'd say it's
possible it's possible that the [ __ ]
other is it pie is it possible is it
I miss question cuz I wasn't there I
didn't see the video that the other four
didn't understand the damage that was
being done to his neck I'll tell you
this right now let's say you look for
him at some weird beef let's say and he
came in to do the show and you guys
start fighting yeah and you you
eventually got Fahim down and you were
grabbing him putting your knee into his
neck
yeah Oh Brian you're you're gonna [ __ ]
him up - yeah what are you doing yeah
but now you where we have carpet here
now imagine you're on blacktop yeah and
the cop is using the car as leverage and
driving the knee into the night yeah
[ __ ] you how just as a human being take
out being a cop do you dude you're gonna
kill what's the rest they're all bad
they're all pieces of [ __ ] yeah how does
not one of them go dude get the [ __ ] off
he's gonna die eight minutes you know
fast a guy can choke you out yeah eight
dude eight minutes and he was begging
for apparently yes I think there's got
to be serious for percussions for this
type of stuff why just have to go to
prison do you otherwise if they just
lost their jobs the governor came out
does that well the mayor goes well don't
worry about the lawsuit you don't
understand that's not good enough
those guys have to pay those guys have
to pay and then you look at the city of
Minneapolis knowing that this isn't good
enough do you have the picture that chin
the streets are filled yeah Mecca should
be filled
it's not a race issue it's a human issue
yes like you do that to a human being
this kid happened 2020 man yeah and then
I think this this puts a little more
spotlight on Kaepernick where we gave it
done a [ __ ] oh you don't really want to
play football I even said that like dude
how about that
we can't breathe look and that's not a
black thing that's a human thing that's
why black Mexicans write Indian that's
and that's that bad that's actually a
good thing right there when you see that
you're like there you go that's worth
that's worth protesting well this shows
you the power of the people the
government don't have the power the
power the people do because if no one
did any of this those guys don't lose
their job you know though that guy that
murdered in Georgia they were gonna let
those guys out yeah yeah until finally
it got brougt light and then people get
held accountable and then they gotta do
something about it
they were just gonna fight they weren't
gonna fire those guys so there's this
huge protest yep it's not Smith let me
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]